hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Robert James Fischer and Boris
Vasudev it's boskie now if you've been
with us so far you know that Fischer is
two points in the leader at the current
score is five and a half to three and a
half and Fischer again has the white
pieces so it will be very interesting
will he continue with his c4 ideas
perhaps he will go d4 or perhaps will he
will return to his original
efore ideas now we've already mentioned
that you know there was a lot of trouble
with the cameras and with the recording
of the match and when Fisher found out
that game eight was recorded without his
knowledge he really went furious and he
was already well the match was going
pretty much in his favor he started
winning you know he did want to try and
open negotiations again to the placement
of the cameras and such but when he
heard that to give me towards the record
without his knowledge he really went
furious and said no more recording and
American recording tell television one
led by mr. Chester Fox had no choice but
to return home so no more recording for
this match and it will be it will mean
some $100,000 or less for the organizers
of this match which would be really
terrible and ashamed for for it to
affect the actual prize fund but the
Icelandic Chess Federation said that
they will you know whatever money they
needed they will they will find the
money as they were planning some sort of
a fishing war they were planning on
expanding their territorial waters for
450 miles so a lot more fish will be
caught and a lot more money will be made
and also it's it's very interesting that
people said that Fischer it's hard to
say if you really cared about money who
would do such a thing if you really if
you really wanted the money and people
started making jokes that Fischer really
didn't even understand the difference
between $10,000 and $100,000 since he
really didn't spend all that much
but okay now that all this was a certain
done also a very interesting fact is
that Fischer used to eat a lot of salty
herrings during the during the games so
he really had to drink a lot of water
and he said that Icelandic water was
really the best he said that and the
rest of the world had this kind of water
like 200 years ago but in Iceland you
know there was no pollution yet and the
water was excellent but okay now
returning to the game Fisher has the
white pieces and he again opens with E
for this time so no more surprises for
Spassky now it's time to play a normal
chess as Pascal goes be five we have
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 and interestingly Spassky really
didn't care about any any recordings or
television rights or or the $100,000
that will be left out of the organizers
because he had bigger problems to tackle
a6 will have more for his defense to the
real Lopes I worship to a4 Knight to f6
we have castles Bishop to e7 rook to e1
and now b5 Bishop to b3 and here Fischer
already plated this position against
Spassky in 1966 in the second
Piatigorsky Cup in Santa Monica
Spassky Spassky castles here and after
c3 Spassky actually went for the
Marshall attack but Marshall attack was
thoroughly analyzed throughout the years
so he doesn't go for that anymore
he has something else in mind and I
think Fischer new world that's possibly
will go for this as Spassky knew that
Fischer knew that he was going to go for
that d6 we have see three castles
Fischer goes h3 and here comes spassky's
favorite line Knights to be eight this
is the brayer line of the rule opus our
black wants to immediately fix his a
pawn chain on the Queen side and the
riemann over this night to further
control the c5 square and Fisher has a
very interesting way of dealing with
this now we have d4 ok Knight B to d7
and now comes the night beat 1937 and
the knight B to d2
also in the tournament we already
mentioned in this
and Piatigorsky Cup in 1966 for santa
monica fisher tried nice to h4 against
Rio Sportage and it was a it was a nice
move going for that f5 square but here
Knight B to d2 comes as an improvement
Bishop to b7 Spassky simply develops the
light square Bishop Bishop to see to
further controlling the e4 pawn rook to
e8 and now comes before this was
Fisher's idea attacking the the main
idea of the prayer line that c5 move so
here Bishop to f8 by Spassky a very nice
move the rook now is very nicely placed
on the e-file gelila rich also mentions
that upon sacrifice with a five with the
idea that if B captures an a5 now you
can execute c5 isn't all that great
because of a4 and here after rook
captures rook to be one the bishop on b7
is unguarded and if you want to prevent
white from creating a passed pawn with a
capture some b5 then you have to play
captures here characters here and then
push b4 but by doing this ok you do get
a pass point yourself but you give white
to this excellent outpost for his Knight
and see for a5 is coming and it will be
a very enjoyable position to play for
white so after b4 Bishop to f8 and the
now comes a four by Fischer we have nice
to be six and now a five in the 1970
tournament of peace in Romanian Zagreb
draggled miniature tried eight captures
and be five against Tigran Petrosian but
after he captures on b5 there was no
real way for white to they'll go for any
advantage here so instead Fischer
doesn't capture he pushes a five kicks
the knight back we have Knight bd7
now the night from d7 is very nicely
lined at c5 square Bishop to b2 and here
before executing c5 Spassky wants to
further improve his position so first he
plays Queen to be eight so now when all
of these exchanges in the center
happened the Queen will be guarding the
e5 pawn rook to be one an excellent move
by Fischer with rook to be one Fischer
is very nicely defending his Bishop on
b2 which was
undefended Fisher knows that when
everything opens up that the queen will
capture on e5 and that the bishop must
be guarded by the rook also by this move
Fisher is threatening the very
unpleasant c4 which would which would be
a very nice positional advantage for
white so it's very so it's not all that
easy for Spassky to deal with this as
possibly executes c5 nonetheless and
okay we have big actors on c5 pawn
captures on c5 and now pawn captures on
e5 Fischer's idea is that now you have
to capture on e5 because if you move the
knight let's say Knight to h5 then you
get Knight to c4 and here really all
hell breaks loose now if you capture
then your pawn structure on the
queenside it's completely busted and
Queen captures on d7 simply winning back
the piece and if you defended the knight
then the idea is not doing anything with
the knight but rather Bishop the c1 the
bishop is can come very nicely to e3 f4
g5 if needed
you still can't capture because your
Bishop is undefended on b7 and the white
would simply have an excellent game here
so after D captures on e5 s possibly has
to capture we have Knight captures on e5
Knight captures on e5 and now comes
Queen captures on e5 and here comes the
idea the rogue who guards the bishop so
Fisher is able to execute c4 now without
Spassky being able to pull before as
first he has to react to this attack
Queen to f4 attacking the knight and
preparing to attack the knight a second
time so first Bishop captures on f6
removing the defend the attacker against
the e4 pawn and with this move Fischer
now threatens to win a pawn and okay
Queen captures and now comes C capture
some b5 simply grabbing a pawn and now
if pawn captures rook captures here but
play six rook simply moves back white is
up upon and with a very nice position at
that so instead as poss he doesn't
recapture rather he plays rook but he
plays rook
eat the d8 very interesting rook a to d8
is not all that great
although it seems like you're bringing
an undeveloped rook into the game and
preparing some Queen to c3 double attack
against the knight and the d a5 pawn
actually after Quintus
and queen 2c3 attacking here white would
have this beautiful bishop to a four
move and now you open up an attack
against the Queen here the thread is
beak a person a six and there is no way
to capture the piece here if you capture
character capture then comes the B
captures on a six opening up an attack
against the bishop against the rook
after rook moves rook captures captures
captures and after rook b2 is simply
protected and the two passed pawns on
the Queen side are easily winning so
Spassky sees this not rook a to d8 but
rather lucky 38 very nicely done
Queen to c1 Fischer has to get out of
the pin twin to c3 attacking the knight
and the a5 pawn and now simply Knight to
f3 Spassky grabs the pawn on e5 and now
Fischer doesn't wait a waste time with
big afters on a6 and Bishop captures on
a6 rather he plays the brilliant move
Bishop to b3 Bishop to b3 seems like
it's it's a move that is actually going
for the f7 pundit but it's a move that's
actually going for the undefended Bishop
on b7 seems like this entire game
revolves around spassky's undefended
bishop on b7 and but you'll see how
Fischer does it eight characters and b5
so grabbing yet another for now Spassky
is the one who is up upon it's very
interesting you know World Chess
Championship match from being up upon
you find a brilliant maneuver that gives
up a pawn but gives you a a nice attack
Queen to f4 going for Queen captures on
f7 and now you'll see the idea C form
will be met with Bishop captures on c4
pawn captures and your Bishop is
undefended and b7 threatening Queen
captures on f7 after f6 defending now e5
and white breaks through through so
after Queen to f4 you do have to prevent
this we have looked at the 7 and now
Knight to e5 comes with an attack on the
rook and the triple attack against the
f7 pawn queen to c7 only move that pins
the night
you cannot capture on f7 because the
queen is undefended on f4 and now comes
a brilliant move by Fischer you can even
you you know feel free to enjoy this
position you know just
stare at it and but yeah you can even
pause the video and try to find the best
move for white here it's really a subtle
move but but it really destroys black so
I'll give you a couple of seconds if you
decide maybe you want to do it so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are a true expert of
chess and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show the rook is rook B to
D one Ruby to D one simply introduces
another attacker against this rook on d7
the problem is if you capture the rook
then you get Bishop captures on f7 and
black is lost of course you cannot
capture because you lose the Queen and
the only then recapture the rook and on
the other hand if you don't if you play
King to h8 then Knights to g6 check you
have to capture because Bishop is
guarding the g8 square Queen to h4 this
is checkmate so you cannot capture the
rook here here is Posse played rook to
e7 he has to get the rock out of the way
but also keep an eye on the f7 pawn and
only now that the rook is controlling
the D file
rook to d7 will be an idea Bishop
captures on f7 beautiful beautiful game
by Fischer again you cannot move because
96 captures and now Queen to h4 will be
checkmate
so rook captures on f7 you have to give
up the exchange we have Queen captures
on f7 Queen captures Knight captures and
now you see the problem of the
undefended bishop if King captures rook
to d7 check and look picks up the bishop
and all okay you do have to pass pawns
on the Queen side but the two rooks
advantage will be I will be too much to
handle
so after Knight to f7 we have Bishop
captures on e4 first and now rook
captures on e4 it's very interesting
some of you might have an idea that nice
to h6 is the way to go if black will
already capture the knight then why not
mess up his pawns on the Kings side the
problem is if you do this and only then
capture then white black can already
start pushing with c4 and this will be a
most valuable temple
so instead not wasting time with Knight
to h6 rook captures immediately and now
it's black that has to waste time
capturing a knight
King characters on f7 and now comes rope
d7 check King to f6 and now look to b7
guarding attacking this pawn and now you
cannot push c4 you will have to push b4
to simply protect the pawn and this will
be much worse for black as he will have
to put his pawns on on the dark squares
and he has a dark square Bishop rook to
e1 check by Spassky now we have King to
h2 and now comes in Bishop to d6
developing the bishop would check g3 and
now before defending the pawn that was
attacked on b5 we have came to g2
getting the King into the game h5 by
Spassky and now comes rock to b6
attacking the bishop rook to d1
defending the bishop and now King to f3
and here as poss he has to make his 40th
move and he has to seal this move the
game will be adjourned after this move a
lot of people said that with the g5
Fischer is a king side majority would
would have been less dangerous and
perhaps Spassky would have greater
chances here as opposed to play King to
f7 and there doesn't seem to be anything
wrong with this move I mean justice just
as good as g5 King to e2 attacking the
rook by Fischer after the game was
continued rook to d5 and now f4 we have
g6 and now g4 pawn captures pawn
captures and now g5 even Spassky wants
the push f5 entry perhaps create some
sort of a castle here as he wants to use
the 5 square with his Bishop to perhaps
create some sort of a blockade but
Fischer doesn't mind f5 we have Bishop
to e5 and now comes a rope to b5 a
beautiful move by Fischer really taking
advantage of of you know small
inaccuracies in spassky's position now
the problem is the threat is a rook
captures on b4 as the rook on d5 is
undefended there is no way to defend
against this you can't get the King in
because the pawn is guarding d6 square
you cannot move the rook because the
rook has to keep an eye on the bishop so
you're losing upon here regardless of
what of what you do we have King to f6
and the now comes rook captures here
Bishop to d4 and now look to b6 check
King moves to d5 and now King to f3 here
we have looked to d8 now comes rook to
b8 not allowing not allowing the
spassky's rook to go for the a file
sorry about that
of course if you play something like
pawn captures here then of course rook
to e6 will be checkmate for a lot to
mention this a very nice idea but here
after Luke to d8 a Fisher doesn't allow
Spassky to use the a file for his road
as fast he still tries it rook d7 rook
b7 room d6 rook b6 and now again after
rook d7 now come to look to g6 going
after the last the g5 pawn that well now
and now Fischer will be able to push his
the two two connected past bonds King d5
would have rook captures here and now
Bishop to e5
we have f6 but the bishop cannot capture
because it's bent King moves and now the
bishop can capture but now Fischer plays
rook to be won and it was in this
position on move 56 that body's
faciliate Spassky resigned the game
there is nothing really to do here rook
to d1 is the threat of rook is coming to
a5 that will simply start pushing his
passport and of course if you capture
them simply again we're up to d1 and you
will you can even capture here and then
enjoy your rook and pawn against the
bishop endgame so after rook to be one
as possibly resigned the game and the
result is now six and a half to three
and a half in Fishers favor so Fischer
increases his lead by three points and
now after after 10 games it will be
extremely hard for Spassky to make up
for this three three point the
difference but you know it's just
anything can happen so we'll definitely
see how it goes yeah and I do hope you
enjoyed the cold bye bye Setzer glitch
also it kinda is the title of the video
but yeah definitely not the greatest
July for Boris Spassky I would like to
thank Citarum ear Roberto cozy Phillip
Colby Goss coleus and get her the winter
Stein for a conversion to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I'll see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon